one of the things with LTR is that just
about every guy gets wrong and give this
away for free as a frame component of it
and
like you know our friend here that was
in a three-year LTR with the nurse and
they're traveling around the traveling
nurses sort of things I know that some
people have issues with nurses
um I think the general consensus by men
out there today is that there's certain
professions where women are more
promiscuous than others and I think that
nurses got caught up in that
Vortex so generally speaking I think
most guys that have had any experience
with nurses have found them to be
incredibly promiscuous they're also
around very successful wealthy doctors
too a lot no not all doctors are alpha
males a lot of them are are Goofs but
they do get a lot of a lot of exposure
to a ton of different people you know
because the work that they do but frame
is something that you can control
um
from you know from the get-go so he ran
in the problem where she loses the way
and then she does oh I'm a diamond so
you have to shine on a diamond and the
light has to come on and the only way
you can do that is if you have a public
Instagram and take you know provocative
photographs that's like at year three
you get to that part at year three
at year one when you start dating a
check like as soon as a chick's like hey
Rich I dig your Vibe where Did We Stand
we've been seeing each other for a while
I want to claim you I don't want anybody
else to have you can we be exclusive
blah blah as soon as you get to that
point
that's when you start looking at her
going okay
she doesn't have any of my red flags
daddy issue she's not a feminist she's
not unhappy or unlucky she doesn't try
to compete with me she doesn't keep men
around from her past she's not poor with
money she's you know she knows how to
deal with money she's not violent she
doesn't have extreme jealousy she's not
a party girl she doesn't have tattoos or
piercings she doesn't have a big Notch
count not a single mom she doesn't seek
validation online she's not a sugar baby
she's not a pathological liar doesn't
have baby rabies doesn't throw Hissy
Fits uh I'm in I'm in full control of
the birth birth control she's not a
drama queen and she doesn't have an
addictive personality
that's when I would be like okay she
doesn't have any of those things or
maybe there's one thing there or two
things there that's when you bring it up
and you're like you know
uh let's pick one here off the list
number 13 seeking seeking validation you
know I like you too but
I noticed that you have your Instagram
public and it looks like you're posting
you know relatively provocative
photographs of yourself to the public
um
I like you too but I don't date women
that do that right like I I just can't
take you seriously right I mean what are
you looking for here you know exactly
like is this like what is the Where Do
We Stand talk like what do you want this
relationship that you're painting right
now to look like because you can't have
that conversation three years down the
road like he tried to where he was like
you know I don't really like these
photographs
um you know this is going to work out
for me and she's like I'm a diamond in
the rough you have to shine on me and I
gotta put my tits out there for
everybody to see you're kind of screwed
to that point right so
by the time you get to year three and
you've gone through bitizations for a
few concessions by the time she's gotten
away with a few things or maybe piled on
some more things maybe year one she had
no tattoos and piercings but by year
three she's got five of them or
something like that maybe she's throwing
Hissy Fits you know and you're not
you're not setting those boundaries and
stopping it from happening that's what
frame is and that's not explained enough
and I'm going to explain it in an
in-depth detail in that course material
when I put it out but that's an
incredible incredibly important part of
that entire equation
Mike's in the chat still he says it's my
fault and if I have a kind and
submissive woman it's my fault if I have
a bossy narcissistic woman absolutely
right I'm keeping myself busy and
focused I'm documented this whole
process on my newly created YouTube Mike
Tyson I'm going to change it eventually
to World is Yours thanks Rich
cheers buddy thanks for the Super Chat
and uh yeah let's see how it unfolds let
me know how you make out but yeah it's
it's
it's at that start it's at that
beginning point where she's like where
do we stand I want to claim you that
you're in the best position to say
cool but I don't date girls that post
provocative pictures on Instagram or
have Snapchats or you know
um they hide their phone or they turn it
down or they're like you know doing this
sort of stuff when you're around like
there's any number of behaviors which
it's not controlling
it's just setting healthy boundaries
right like I don't park my McLaren next
to a piece of [ __ ] rusted ass truck in a
big parking lot when I could park it
over there away from something that's
going to hit it right it's just being
and I lock it when I walk away from it I
don't leave it unlocked to throw the key
on the seat I lock it and I walk away
from it I park it in a responsible
well-lit area especially if it's at
night time it's under light and I look
around are there cameras right like
that's what you do it's the same thing
when you get into an LTR you make sure
that you take appropriate steps
especially if she's doing the where do
we stand and I want to claim you or if
she's going hardcore on you and I want
to be monogamous I don't want anybody
else to see you fine okay if that's if
that's where you're at but
these things need to happen for this to
work out because home you don't play
that game you don't want to do that get
the [ __ ] out of here
right and you'll be in a good position
do that and not really care because
you'll be spinning plates and you'll
have options hey guys I really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out